[Music]
this is warren buffett one of the
richest people in the world thanks to
the company he runs berkshire hathaway
basically it's a holding company that
just owns a bunch of other companies
geico dairy queen a huge railroad as
well as a lot of stock in other
companies like apple and coca-cola
so when those companies do well and
their stock goes up berkshire hathaway
stock goes up
when buffett took over the company in
1965 a single share was worth nineteen
dollars
today it's worth nearly half a million
dollars
buffett owns nearly 240 000 of these
shares
this is where his wealth is
but as he's been known for pointing out
warren buffett still pays a lower tax
rate than his secretary she pays at
twice the rate i pay i think that's
outrageous that's because they pay
different types of taxes his secretary
pays income taxes on her salary but
buffett mainly pays capital gains taxes
on his sold stock and that's taxed at
nearly half the rate
the wealthy
are definitely
under tax in the u.s the disparity
between the richest americans and
everyone else has been growing and in
the last 40 years the after-tax income
of the richest has risen more than 400
while middle-class income has only risen
50. the way these people make money is
very different than the way these people
make money
and they're not taxed the same
[Music]
i pay less in taxes than people that
work for a living
and make as much money as i do this is
morris he used to work on wall street
now he's retired and lives off his many
stock market investments i own stock in
companies i mean berkshire hathaway and
amazon and apple
he's a pretty typical one percenter
except that he spends his money
advocating for rich people like him to
be taxed more i want to live in a
country filled with a middle class of
people who can all afford to shop in our
businesses
most people have a normal job they get a
paycheck and pay income tax ranging from
10 to 37 percent
but people like morris they make a lot
of their income from investments
generally stocks in real estate
these investments are taxed as capital
gains and things like long-term stock
have a maximum tax rate of just 20
percent i sold some stock
recently for four hundred thousand
dollars and my
taxes on that's around fifty thousand
dollars
but that fifty thousand dollars is far
less tax than anyone who has a job
making four hundred thousand dollars a
year would pay
and most of his wealth well isn't even
taxable people like morris or buffett
are worth so much money because of the
stock that they hold but it's not
tangible spendable taxable money i can
look at my stock portfolio and i can say
oh you know i made a million dollars
this year but it doesn't have to be
anything in taxes
because our system is based on only
paying taxes when you actually sell
something amazon's jeff bezos the
richest man in america thanks mostly to
his amazon stock pays almost nothing in
taxes
we value his worth here but it's never
taxed unless it's turned into real money
when he sells the stock and it's taxed
as a capital gain
this is one way billionaires are able to
be technically worth so much money but
pay so little in taxes
some billionaires like elon musk are
able to get loans against their stocks
and live off of that they don't even
need to sell the stock to turn it into
spendable money no sale no taxes
the fact is if you're a billionaire
you don't need any income
there's also a big loophole in capital
gains taxes that the rich exploit called
the stepped-up basis
if hypothetically warren buffett were to
sell his stock he'd have to pay capital
gains taxes based on his profit so the
cost of the stock minus the original
investment
but if he holds off selling his entire
life when he dies whoever inherits the
stock and then sells it would only have
to pay taxes on what they earned after
they inherited it
leaving all those original gains untaxed
it's part of what's called buy borrow
die and it's one way the richest
families avoid paying taxes
it's this system and the fact that most
taxable capital gains are going to the
top one percent that lawmakers see
changing the capital gains tax as an
easy way to tax the rich
president biden has proposed closing
that stepped up loophole and increasing
the maximum tax rate from 20 to 39.6
but just for people making more than a
million dollars a year
critics argue that it may discourage
people from investing in the stock
market or that current millionaires
would just sell less stock but it would
bring in more tax revenue from more
conservative estimates of 200 billion
over 10 years to double that
it would also mean buffett would pay a
closer tax rate to a secretary
but this pile of unrealized money still
goes untaxed
there's a lot of things we could do to
make the system more fair we could have
taxes on wealth we could have taxes on
gains in the stock market most americans
are bothered that wealthy people don't
pay their fair share and changing
capital gains taxes wouldn't be the
whole solution but advocates argue it
would be an easy place to start our
system is making the rich get richer and
richer and richer
and everyone else just
not
[Music]
you